hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're gonna talk about what's really
behind leaky gut okay now you've
probably been told that well gluten will
cause it and that's true that's the
protein in wheat but what happens when
you cut out the gluten and you still
have the problem and it's not clearing
up or people that really don't consume
any gluten what's the cause then there's
something else it's basically a version
of scurvy scurvy of your colon that's a
vitamin C deficiency now I did some
videos on this with the arteries because
when you have scurvy of the arteries or
a vitamin C deficiency of the arteries
you can start having these little leak
leaks that go into the blood vessel and
it creates an immune reaction and it
starts getting formation of cholesterol
and calcium and then you get this clot
well a similar thing happens in the
colon when you see vitamin C controls
the collagen formation so when you're
deficient in vitamin C you'll get
symptoms of like bleeding gums that's
because the capillaries are breaking
down and you're getting bleeding okay
well guess what happens you have this
little lining a layer of cells in your
colon that allow food to be absorbed
through there like a route light
structure into the lymphatic system
where you absorb the nutrients normally
those little gaps are between 1 and 7
microns very very very small when you
have leaky gut it becomes 200 to 300
microns so you have these huge holes in
your colon and that's gonna allow
undigested proteins to go through the
colon well guess what happens it doesn't
get the stamp of approval through from
your immune system immigration and so
your body starts attacking and building
antibodies against those proteins
thus the massive food allergies
specifically to proteins and food
sensitivities to other foods as well but
here you have all these food allergies
simply because of this vitamin C
deficiency so you've got food allergies
and then you have immune reaction you
have inflammation scar tissue and now
you can't absorb
after that because it's it's just not
working and you have these like these
malformed junctions okay so here's a
question like why are you deficient in
vitamin C in the first place could it be
your diet is it because you don't
consume enough vegetables you need a
good amount of vegetables at least seven
cups every single day to eat your
vitamin C when you take a supplement
most vitamin C comes in a synthetic
version ascorbic acid and some people
take that and think they're getting the
whole vitamin C complex but in reality
vitamin C in nature comes in different
parts so if I were to show you right
here vitamin C has a very small
protective outer shells called ascorbic
acid but inside you have the P factors
about flavonoids okay ba flavonoids and
then you have the J factor since the
anti pneumonia vitamin increases oxygen
copper and vitamin K so you have a lot
of complex things inside that vitamin C
complex that's how nature has designed
vitamin C the one that is really
specifically aligns to this problem it
is the deficiency in the P factor the
bowel flavonoids so when you take
ascorbic acid you don't get any bowel
flavonoids okay so it really doesn't
work so here's some foods that are very
very important that are very high in
bioflavonoids to help heal that collagen
sprouted buckwheat okay you can get I
would get that as a supplement find a
supplement a sprouted buckwheat there's
one from santa process called Sirota
plus that's one there's others on Amazon
I'll put some some information down
below I don't have any brands that I'm
recommending other than santa process is
a good one
cure certain is a bal flavonoid parsley
onions green tea
citrus lemons limes all these are very
high in bioflavonoids a lot of the
vegetables most of the vegetables
especially cruciferous are loaded with
ba flavonoids but let's say you're
consuming these foods but you're still
having this problem
it could be it's not that your diet is
deficient about NEC it's that you have
insulin resistance you have too much
insulin you're pre-diabetic or you have
symptoms of a subclinical pre-diabetes
which is not really showing up but you
have all the symptoms that see hi this
is gonna create a lot more insulin and
higher insulin will deplete your vitamin
C boom that's one thing so you have to
correct that if that's the problem the
other cause of vitamin C deficiencies is
smoking one cigarette if you smoke one
cigarette you're gonna deplete at least
25 grams of vitamin C so here you're
smoking and then you're depleting it
you're not knowing that's causing that
can set you up for a vitamin C
deficiency okay so I just wanted to give
you some solutions to this problem right
here to actually help heal this and
these are some good things and also
you're gonna have to stop smoking if you
are smoker but that's gonna really help
you as well thanks for watching hi guys
hey listen I created a pretty amazing
evaluation quiz down below that actually
analyzes your symptoms to find the cause
the root cause of all of your symptoms
the most likely cause so take the quiz
now and we'll send you a report